[Musik]
jeden tag versuchen in der schweiz rund
50 menschen ihr leben selbst zu beenden
und überleben es im jahr sind das etwa
20.000
warum fragt man sich drei von ihnen
erzählen ihre geschichte
mehrere serien in denen das ist dass sie
dafür dass das macht es sehr schmal film
aus ihren problemen mit dem mit mir
homosexualität damit die option
blitzschlag ist für nicht akzeptiert
dass jetzt adoptierte und die leute ist
ob russland akzeptiert als schweizer
oder so und dann perfekt und er bitte
denken sie einfach die taktik gilt
fortan erlebt und von staatlicher stange
neue liszt gerade 31 geworden das
überraschte ihn selbst hat das leben ihn
doch schon in jungen jahren oft
überfordert beim ersten suizidversuch
war er 16 jahre alt
schon als kleiner junge habe er sich
zerrissen gefühlt und fremd und viele
ängste hätten ihn geplagt irgendwann als
er längst erwachsen und in vielen
therapien war bekam sein leiden einen
namen
das borderline-syndrom seit er denken
kann waren da die immer gleichen
drängenden fragen beantworten
er ist darüber fast verzweifelt sie ja
dass das hat mir das ist mir nicht
passieren dass sie jetzt so schwierig
bleibe das hängt auch mit der aktion
ohne probleme auf den teig tun einfach
auf minute war keine rede
und dann sehr problemen kommen
frau nicht genau fest aber garvey und
warten wir gespannt ist
maria [ __ ] kontakt auf und bringen das
zu seinem krankheitsbild gehört auch
dass man sich immer wieder selbst
verletzt das zählt gar ohne stecker und
somit ein bulliger umlauf anime
gesamtwerts ist auch die ohren und im
schnitt lang brauchte sie nur der innere
druck von ideen kann jeder minister
schmied dass unser gott sagen
das habe er jetzt auch wohl mit schnitt
da und zwei stifte schnitt ja aber auch
das jetzt passiert oder so und es ist
einfach sehr schnell hat sich auch schon
selbst in die psychiatrische klinik
einweisen lassen
heute lebt er in einer begleiteten
wohnung einmal die woche kommt ein
betreuer vorbei
zur unterstützung und zur kontrolle nach
wie vor braucht er außerdem
psychologische hilfe
von monique ist gut er sie mit
unterstützen also sich immer wieder
eigentlich sehr kritisch sehe ich heute
nun regelmässig prof
der duft macht den absturz kann sich
denn als oxid als therapeutin
ausgestiegen ist findet sich zum teil
terminen können aber es ist ein entweder
durch einen klinikaufenthalt wieder zu
den wohn begleitung und entwicklung ist
sehr erfreulich
also sie gut major wird die sorge ist
gewisse stabilität unter merkel nur
zuvor haben aber die situation ist
fragil ii suizid das thema immer präsent
im moment beschäftigt neue das schicksal
eines bekannten ja und bis 60
so sieht man natürlich auch
in der schweiz sterben mehr junge männer
durch suizid als durch autounfälle oder
krankheit
[Musik]
nicht immer ist es klar dass es sich um
einen suizid versuch handelt man kann es
nur vermuten wenn beispielsweise bei
einem autounfall bremsspuren fehlen
[Musik]
recycling ist auch wenn die plakate oder
ansprechperson für den pc
aber es übrigens definitiv wiese mit der
berühmten überreden wenn die mitzieht
gedanken zum hausarzt im westen etwas
damit reagiere herrschens verstehe oder
mit zweitens viele touristiker die
klinik 20 easy credit strategy
also das sind also hindernis wurden
keine sehr häufiger spieler das lied
arbeiten sagt nicht wie schnell oder
wenn man suizid gedanken und das
moderate familienangehöriger seit das
leben besuch sondern darum als wichtig
so neutral ist neutral und zutrauen hat
das tier richtig damit umgeht und fertig
gestellt ist aber nicht ganz einfach zu
finden
ursprünglich acht und arbeitet stellt
wechselt und argentinische stelle die
anspannung so groß wurde unter druck
dass sie einfach wiener zusammenbruch
kam von der ich annehme und ideale
situation in europa und der nacht
verschwinden
stimmlich daniel göring ist 47 und lebt
getrennt von seiner familie
kurz vor seinem suizid versuch sieht er
seine drei kinder im schulalter nur noch
an besuchstagen es vermisst ihn niemand
wenn er überstunden macht seine neue
freundin lebt in einem anderen kanton
außer super dass ich sehr dankbar er ist
einer jener manager männer die immer
kämpfen gegen die uhr gegen schwächen
und eigentlich ging sich selbst aber das
weiß er erst seit seinem suizidversuch
jahre lang hat er als mediensprecher
krisen schön reden müssen er selbst
würde das natürlich nie so sagen dass
wir möglichst viele informationen
zusammen die luftfahrt weitgehend
liberalisiert
[Musik]
die golde fokus zu sorgen dass private
die situation dass die familie
auseinander gegangen ist ein floß
klarheit aber es ist wahnsinnig
schwierig zu sagen wie groß ist ihr floß
vorfällen bereich cms klar im
vordergrund ist die belastung am
arbeitsplatz gestanden dass sie töte
einfach nur quatsch wie entschlossen und
eines abends bin ich öfter stündigen
arbeitstag der heimat stand integrität
hochegger fermé und einfach ausgeführt
von monumentalen das nicht anders zeigen
mir vor wie wenn ebene vakuum inneren
und im iran haitianisches war chrome
es ist so lazio und rosigkeit und
ideenlosigkeit sternen plötzlich fragen
auch der story suse und dann hat sich
die gedanken weiter entwickelt und dort
ressourcen ist schloss krieft wort
möglichst schnell und möglichst für
immer am rand unserer prognose wird sich
als effektiv los ohne begleiter skijäger
ohne gesichtsverlust ausweises einfach
verschwendet und möglichst ruhig und
dunkel und darum seine stände der plan
entstanden das mit medikamenten tat
umsetzen
ja denn ganz gezielt zum teil in den
arbeitspausen zum teil nach den vier
oben
die verschiedenen apotheken die
entsprechende medikament besorgt hat
einfach immer schön portioniert damit
wendet unnötiges verdacht geschöpft
er kappte alle sozialen kontakte und
manövrierte sich selbst in die totale
isolation anrufe und sms seiner freundin
blieben unbeantwortet
mit der situation bin ich schon so stark
im studio in exter sowie bundes dass es
keine anderen optionen auf das hoch so
jetzt das ist es und im musik und wort
jetzt tourismus und denen ist als andere
und je weniger zugängliche für
irgendwelche impuls
[Musik]
hunderte möglich von dem medikament
librium ersichtlich wie eine freundin
blüte
das hat nicht erst im nachhinein musik
gefunden und sie hätten sofort
realisiert dass es nicht stimmt und
hätten dissidenten erste markante
rückstand
[Musik]
inzwischen zieht eine mitternacht wieder
verwahrt wie magen um mehr mitgemacht
hat und die haben wir dann übergab
und wieder ein vorgang ist vermutlich
großteil wird eine giftige substanz im
körper motoren ist überhaupt möglich das
militär im ort hat einen blick vom 3
[Musik]
sie erwarte die gesellschaft dass man
stark
depression ist nach wie vor für viele
schwächen 70 prozent aller personen die
einen suizidversuch beginnt leiden an
depressionen
depressionen sind die versteuerung
mittwoch über winter sondern dass sie
veränderungen den stoffwechsel
wenn das länger geduldet den bruch das
einfach liebe handlich fachärztliche
behandlung und dort die sich nach wie
vor möglichkeit für sensibilisieren
münster das nach wie vor sogar in der
schweiz war das sehr gute gesundheit
zwei sei das sehr viel depressionen
nicht behandelt werden und dort sie
frauen betroffen
in der schweiz begehen jeden tag rund 50
menschen einen suizidversuch und
überleben etwas mehr frauen als männer
das geht so wahrscheinlicher ist aber es
tut sich immer so decher das heißt dass
gold immer rufen
und wenn ich nur zurufen und der
kochtopf überholt und so ist beim xii
gabriele fischer ist heute 68 jahre alt
und seinerzeit einer neuen liebe wegen
aus der deutschschweiz ins tessin
gezogen außer ihrem neuen freund kannte
sie niemanden nur ihren hund hatte sie
mitgenommen und war glücklich
trotzdem vor eineinhalb jahren wollte
sie ihr leben beenden
von einem moment auf den anderen ein
effekt huntloser aktie hier am ufer der
brissago inseln soll dereinst ihre asche
verstreut werden
aber erst wenn sie eines natürlichen
todes gestorben sei afrika kennt sich
aus mit dem tod als sterbebegleiterin
hat sie weit über hundert menschen in
den tod begleitet würdevolles sterben zu
ermöglichen war geradezu ihre mission ja
einfach die kehle schicksal und kann
dank des hcd lediglich mit schwarzem uhr
starten die ein techno oder hat sie
ihren wunsch mehr
wenn ihr einfach türe zugemacht und
gegangen honeywell der shop ist gut
gemacht du châtelet die liebesdienste
wisse ja nie schlecht für sich selbst
allerdings sei suizid nie ein thema
gewesen
[Musik]
naja auf 11
doch während ihrer drogistin lehre wurde
sie prompt schwanger und war mit 19
jahren bereits mutter mit dem ersten
familie hund und die tochter
[Musik]
das abkommen ist es wichtig
das ist nach tarif schluss hätte ihr
damals jemand prophezeit sie würde ihr
leben selbst beenden
sie hätte ihn wohl ausgelacht es kam
anders
nach 38 jahren fühlte sie sich nur noch
wie eine schöne weise auf dem schrank
und verließ ihren mann
doch das feuer der neuen liebe brannte
nur kurz sie glaubte trotzdem an die
beziehung
[Musik]
das sehe ich das auto gestanden
mediola absetzen
[Musik]
aber er stösst auch sie machen
davon ist gewesen
[Musik]
dazu kommt dass sie blieb in die stadt
ein
da sie im koma bleiben oder noch teile
im schattigen
[Musik]
dort sie im körper drei wochen sie ganz
für sich
der roller aus dem koma erwachen und
morgen
und wenn das nicht passiert wäre er
sieht maschine nach drei wochen
abgestellt unterschied wie tag bevor die
drei wochen um max season passiert dass
sie langsam wieder
außerdem reiche
ich habe keine rede ich an ihm können
dann laufe ich habe meine scheibe als
nicht weniger
ich bin froh wieder laufen ist der
vorfall
und das ist eben so dass metrik ich bin
eben soviel aus hauptsächlich mit 0 für
sich
samstagmorgen des harz für zwischen
vitamin d
das sind 8 ablenkt
[Musik]
suizidversuche stadt suizid hosted
magath vor höchste bis zu einer million
pro fall
gruß und insofern hat das
volkswirtschaftliche bedeutung
gleichzeitig weiß man wie jeder suizid
rennen verhindern und geld dafür muss
das konservativ geachteten drittel fotos
musik und vermieter werde durch
präventionsmaßnahmen fünf bis zehn
prozent der schweizer bevölkerung
unternehmen mindestens einmal im leben
an suizidversuch daniel göring hat ein
jahr nach seinem suizidversuch ein buch
über sein leiten geschrieben
[Musik]
und jetzt trägt er das tabu in die
öffentlichkeit in eigener sache ist der
auftritt gewohnte mediensprecher
allerdings noch nie aufgetreten
der pensionist frankfurt wo verbreitet
ist und sie wird trotzdem immer noch
totgeschwiegen
erst wenn wir lehre in der gesellschaft
oft nicht darüber zu reden können wir
mit krankheit und infolge besserer
umgang der verstöße stehen die was er
mit den betroffenen vor gott und mir
wissen als betroffene dass es vage geht
wie man depression überwinden und wieder
es normalausleger führen musste eine
grünen habe mich entschlossen meine
geschichte der öffentlichkeit tragen und
das buch
[Musik]
damit ließ er offen mit dem thema um mir
eigentlich nur stunden ja einfach will
es so schnitt über die schulter gucken
sie damit der ganze sache darum ihre
vorgänger
ich denke wäre mir zu mehr konnten
seither haben sie mit doppelter so das
hat meine art wie man seine musik spüren
das ist zurück zu null
neben ihm hatten seine adoptiveltern
zwei eigene und drei andere
adoptivkinder
er ist mit keinem verwandt
[Musik]
es gab mehr sehr gut tanzen und die auch
mit ihrer tante und den mit der nahrung
schlechter und daher und dann zutritt
[Musik]
sehr wenig
ohne wurzeln in einem kleinen dorf im
mittelland aufzuwachsen ist
anspruchsvoll
[Musik]
musik heilt sagte ihm seine mutter immer
wieder darum saß er schon als
jugendlicher oft hier mit amerika
[Musik]
die letzte große krise sitzt nur noch
immer in den knochen
[Musik]
das ist profi aktiv ist und das ist
schlimm sehr wohl dafür wir sagen klar
die damen sind und bieten dort recycelt
und hat dann einfach
[Musik]
seit er okay geworden sei gehe es ihm
viel besser sagt er
die kinder seiner adoptivtochter
aufwachsen zu sehen gebe seinem leben
sinn
[Musik]
sie haben sie reagiert als vater rossi
das gestand dass er 2005 die strang
autos etwa doch nicht so blöd und auch
schon für schlichter kommt sie sehen die
wieder einschalten und ihn fort und
endet eigentlich das ganze bis 1980
unity geschrieben ich wie es
normalerweise
[Musik]
ja denn und angst
zufällig kam damals seine schulkameraden
pia vorbei und so hinweg vom gleis trotz
ihrer kürzlichen hüftoperation ist sie
wieder an den ort gekommen wo sie neues
schicksal entschied abgefüllt und gleich
heute ist wieder zeit für modo immer mit
denen gerade verbraucht und nach
womit den gleiter und so bin ich
eigentlich schon flog sie also ja und
deshalb wohl deshalb getäuscht haben wir
nie verloren
eine dame und sieben rauter das womit
der bitte sie herzlich gott überhaupt da
bin ich auch froh ist er dass der text
mit den drogen aber auch formal mit der
erste drogen und der deponie für muss
einfach nimmer die neue wii einfach
nicht gesichert also jo und daher dauert
einfach gar nicht zu mir zu mir geglückt
und die chance was der lange wie es den
anderen gebiet oder was wenn man merkt
dass man sich mit sich selber der frauen
im zusammenhang steht
man muss schon sein ja das geht
st also ich bin froh dass sie
[Musik]
gabriele fricke kehrte nach fünf monaten
in der psychiatrischen klinik in die
wohnung zurück ihr freund war weg in der
nachbarschaft wusste niemand über den
suizidversuch bescheid aber es wurde
gemunkelt einer nachbarin kam das alles
komisch vor
sie ist heute ihre freundin damals
kannten die beiden sich nur vom sehen
bei den hunden spaziergängen sich total
zurück ließ nicht locker und die
freundschaft
ich bin eigentlich mit wenig ironie der
geschichte
hollande hat vor über 30 jahren auch
einen suizidversuch überlebt vielleicht
rührt daher dass verständnis für die
situation und der mut die unbekannte
nachbarin anzusprechen
sie ist natürlich eine frau sie ist nun
so strahlend
das hat natürlich schon seine spuren
und das hat ja jetzt bin
[Musik]
langsam sucht gabriele den weg zurück in
die gesellschaft allerdings noch
vorsichtig
[Musik]
einfach ist es nicht gewesen
sie war mit unverständnis aus ihrem
umfeld konfrontiert und die probleme
haben sich nicht von selbst gelöst
nie hätte die frühere yogalehrerin
gedacht dass sie an diesem punkt kommen
könnte und sogar in der psychiatrie
landen würde
und jetzt musste sie mit dem leben
wieder irgendwie neu anfangen
ich bin froh dass ich meine tochter
nicht so eine schwere geburt überlebt
und freundliche kleine tochter ist ja
nicht sexy vorher aber dass der
schicksalsschlag
aber die tiere auch nicht repariert
ich danke menschen schwierige
situationen psychologischen ausspruch
das wäre mir und ich bin immer neue
behandlung
psychotherapeutin ich sehe sich 14 tage
retten und die von ihm seit ihr gedanken
was sind jetzt dass verträge über
[Musik]
herrschte dass man sich selber
gescheitert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn man eine identische und dass ich
das war immer sehr schwierig wie ist das
möglich
dass er mit seiner familie das rathaus
kindheit und dort weiß man mit
psychologischer sicht ein
psychologischer modell das man verwende
sonne so eine problemlösung strategie
für betroffene im nachhinein ausfall
sind ganz klar noch mal wieder im moment
kein techniker waren haben etwas zu
haben wäre profilierte vernünftige
mensch und offen diese zahl zwei
zivilpersonen wenn sie nachher trotzdem
zur stadt sich völlig normal ist dass
das - klasse nicht das ist schwer
nachzuvollziehen aber dass ich offenbar
einfach weiterfuhr user software das
mehrtägige treffen
juni dann später arbeit in den klagen
die relativ emotionslos festgestellt
dass eine funktioniert der letzte werk
ohne arbeit beschritten
diesen mut braucht sondern spd und das
problem ist dass sie keine daniel göring
hat seinen suizid versucht zwar überlegt
wie er danach weiter liegen konnte hat
er erst in der reha-klinik geis gelernt
dort haben sich verschiedene therapeuten
die zähne an ihnen aus gewissen einer
hat ihn achtsamkeit mit sie selbst
gelehrt das konnte er irgendwann
annehmen und in den alltag integrieren
und halt macht
das hilft wirklich nochmal nachlesen wo
noch der hund sehr schmal zu mir ins
büro ich ständig mir sehr gespannt die
person and go on exzesse ich das sehr
schnelle redefluss simon rekord und
tätig die spanische sprache wenn er ist
ihr ihn gespürt hat
rezept wird die nicht sagen aber der
bedienungsanleitung im umgang mit mir
selbst auf der ente sieht dann aber auf
der anderen verhalten gegenüber der
umwelt und frauen im arbeitslager
das rad dreht glücklich langsam verglich
und er sehr schmal zu mir ruhig viel
ruhiger
das ist gott sichtbar und es ist viel
gelassener und ruhiger da also näher als
erst mal zu mir ruhig im suizid ist der
wunsch aus den usa wo man drin ist und
das wird er als möglichkeit eröffnet
sich musste im sitzen und maschine
andere möglichkeiten sich die zum umsatz
hob es anders wäre es gibt keinen rezept
aber eine art instrumentarium um den
abwärtsstrudel zu stoppen
daniel göring hat gelernt neue ziele zu
programmieren oder ganz einfach
langsamer und dafür vielleicht länger zu
leben
ich habe früher immer der anspruch kann
das wenn ihr büro von oder gewarnt dass
sie möglichst schnell kommen wie das auf
der wanderer werke ag chs ist und mit
den erfahrungen aus der klinik an ihm
sofort gestellt und gesagt so dass mal
dass sie möglichst oft länger und werden
das unter einer glocke und als
tatsächlich geschafft den wandel galaxis
aus dem thron
[Musik]
obwohl er seine freundin vor dem
suizidversuch mehrmals vor den kopf
gestoßen habe war sie auch noch da als
er wieder aus der klinik zurück kam
[Musik]
so realisiert dass sich ein unternehmen
der metro ag hat das nicht aus berufs
angebot interpretiert für missverstehe
belästigung und das ist ein bisschen in
italy und darum eine zusehends denn dann
aber angefangen sie zurückwiesen das ist
sehr überraschend quasi team nicht
zutraut und das medikament ist also sich
für mich als clegg frau ich das also
völlig das logo das erste medikament
über und wer weiß wer strikte dass das
mir als die kontakte werden wenn man
sich zurückerinnert was abgelaufen ist
ist das baby nur als studien nach dass
die notwendige kraft und geduld
aufbringt und brands bliebe aber wenn
wir beweise aus partner aus ost stehen
da war es ist eine person in den ablauf
der besuchszeit effektiv die nötige
geduld und relativ höfliche
frustrationstoleranz
[Musik]
was ist das leben
ich habe einfach das schöne monika
christ werden miteinander funktioniert
sind und einfach wirkliche anwählen ganz
genau gehöre und das hat er mir nix das
ist auch in einer phase
ich habe mir einfach vorstellen dass
metro legen wollten ein bisschen texas
verheiratet jeder der täglich 50
suizidversuche ist ein drama auch für
die angehörigen und täglich sterben in
der schweiz drei menschen durch suizid
das müsste nicht sein würde mehr in die
prävention investiert suizidprävention
gesehen als es thema farben wie beim
verzehr sollten verhindern dass linie
fehler zu große kriege führen direkt die
präventionsmaßnahme betreffe die
sogenannte hotspots oder sind die orte
schweiz wo man statistisch erwiesen dass
häufiger suizid passiert das könnte sie
das entpacken sie das könnt straße sie
wo menschen in ihrer not sich eine
situation setzen wo sie einen unfall
ihres lappe verliert zwei wochen nach
dem letzten gespräch mit 0 hat er die
traurige gewissheit sein bekannter hat
sich das leben genommen
hier in der nähe hat man ihn im rhein
gefunden
die beerdigung wäre ihm zu viel gewesen
sein bester freund begleitet ihn zu
einer gedenk minute
und da ein bisschen untergegangen
naja wirkung nicht
ja
jetzt mache ich mit
[Musik]
mwst
also extrem arbeit aber den muss man
einfach sauber stoppen und einfach den
mediator sind die spuren mit jedem ort
die zum gerät das in etwas ist damit
zusammen dass sie mit zwei stufen
steigen
negative gedanken dass soziale gedanke
haben sich nicht gut geordnet sie dann
zurück
also wenn ihr weiter wachsen
dann kann ja auch schon was mach ich
versuche also dass nutzer hier ist hilft
also das sagt mir selbst den krieg
automatisch wieder die gedanken
[Musik]
vielleicht reicht es wenn einem jemand
zuhört ohne moralisierende ratschläge
vielleicht braucht es professionelle
hilfe um das leben wieder als mögliche
alternative sehen zu können sich es
letzte und fensterbau r8 von manz über
flattr oder das anti doping labor
befindet das soll also sie das so bliebe
aber bei dir man schon wo sich im rahmen
von der psychischen situation flagge
namen detewe.net ihren freie wähler
folge sondern machen das immer eine
trance zustand und da geht es darum
alles dafür tun dass sie trotzdem
zustande sach und normal und überlege
gibts eine möglichkeit doch ins labor
würdiger ort wieder zu
[Musik]
manchmal ist das ende der anfang